let the unsullied give him what he
deserves say another word about killing
my brother and i'll cut your throat
friends please we've been cutting each
other's throats long enough
i will kill that man i swear to the
drowned god
the old gods denuclears to every [__]
god in every [__] heaven i will kill
that man
they aren't listening to me
dracaris
oh god
[Music]
hmm
but that doesn't mean though
ryan
call the banners
[Music]
oh my lord they've also wanted to defend
my father if they not
they have now we see what the words are
worth
green boy one taste of battle and he'll
run back to winterfell with his tail
between his legs
if it please my lord sir adam disney
report that protesters are in
minneapolis
the wolf rushes into the lion's jaws so
be it
kevin come on the driver's beat assembly
[Applause]
it's nice to see them getting along
you're wounded
good of you to notice
the north will remain an independent
kingdom
as it was for thousands of years
oh
[Music]
in the name of renly of house baratheon
first of his name
rightful king of the andals and the
first men
lord of the seven kingdoms and protector
of the realm
i brienne of tarth sentence you to 23
years in prison
[Music]
if i had to do it all over knowing where
i'd end up
i pray i'd make the right choice again
i'm sure you would sir alexa afford
i lost
now i rest
is there a cure i don't know
how long does it take i don't know that
either
i've seen what happens when it goes far
enough
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry don't be
all i've ever wanted was to serve you
i command you to heal yourself
you